casi 8 años después la rabia de los
familiares de los 43 estudiantes
mexicanos desaparecidos en el estado de
guerrero en septiembre de 2014 sigue
intacta ahora una semana después de que
la comisión de la verdad del país
revelara que la desaparición fue un
crimen de estado los manifestantes
claman más respuestas coraje e
impotencia de que hayan pasado tantos
años y nos hayan mantenido con muy poca
información y la poca información que
había pues eran mentiras el viernes la
comisión de la verdad hizo una nueva
revelación el nombre de un militar
vinculado con el asesinato de seis de
los alumnos de iguala se presume que
seis de los estudiantes se mantuvieron
con vida hasta cuatro días después de
los hechos y que fueron ultimados y
desaparecidos por órdenes del coronel
presuntamente el entonces coronel josé
rodríguez pérez
previamente la comisión desmintió la
llamada verdad histórica del gobierno
del ex presidente enrique peña nieto- lo
que llevó a que jesús murillo karam
quien se desempeñaba como procurador
general del país en el momento de la
desaparición fuera
la verdad histórica culpaba al cartel
guerreros unidos de la desaparición de
acuerdo a esta los criminales habían
secuestrado y asesinado a los 43
estudiantes e incineraron sus cuerpos
sus conclusiones fueron siempre
rechazadas por las familias de las
víctimas y desmentidas por expertos
internacionales de la comisión
interamericana de derechos humanos
además de murillo karam las autoridades
mexicanas emitieron 83 órdenes de
detención contra soldados policías
funcionarios locales y miembros de
bandas criminales
aunque se han recuperado fragmentos de
los huesos incinerados que coinciden con
tres de los estudiantes los cuerpos de
la mayoría de las víctimas siguen
desaparecidos